how many people can fit in one of these
we can fit 38 people into each gather
Gary Loveman is the CEO of Caesars the
world's largest gaming company and I'm
inside his latest gamble the tallest
Ferris wheel on the planet I hear that
I'm gonna be able to actually see all of
Vegas on this at five hundred and fifty
feet high you can't miss the high roller
nor can you beat the views for about 30
bucks you get a half-hour ride and an
eyeful in your own glass enclosed cabin
it can generate 2,200 passengers an hour
so we started looking around at the
world of this type of attraction we
looked at the London Eye we looked at
the roller coaster down here at the
stratosphere and the numbers were
impressive but for Caesars this giant
Ferris wheel isn't just about ticket
sales it's the company's secret weapon
in a decades-long Vegas turf war thirty
years of real estate development on Las
Vegas Boulevard has carved the strip
into sections and Gary's rivals offer
every kind of excess to protect their
territory my competitors have great
facilities to the north and to the south
of us and we own all this property here
in the center of the strode to the north
is Steve Wynn's Empire his two luxury
hotels have learned big spenders away
from Caesars Palace the company's
flagship just a few blocks away for
their South MGM's 11 different
properties have something for every
budget from the low end to the high its
steep competition at every price point
left in the middle is Caesars it's eight
locations which include Paris the
Flamingo and Planet Hollywood are
clustered in the center strip and hungry
for gamblers company lost three billion
dollars last year
well it's really tough I mean you're
here this evening if I were to run
through the list of things you could do
to entertain yourself this evening it's
a remarkable list of things and it's
really what keeps Vegas vibrant is that
all of us through this competition are
adding new things to the offering list
all the time on the one hand that's been
deviling if you're trying to compete on
the other image which keeps the place
Michael Loveman plans to use the
high-roller as a magnet to bring players
back to the hood why do you need to get
people back into the middle this is all
us we have 362 US acres of land around
here including this undeveloped way of
e-bikes so what we want to do is get the
customers of our competitors to have an
interesting coming into what is really
the 50-yard line of Vegas if the high
roller lures them in Loveman side bet
the link keeps them in place what's in
the link is a series of affordable
retail dining and entertainment options
so things like brooklyn-born where you
become your great concert and all drink
and party unique retail experiences that
don't exist anywhere else in Vegas the
Yard House is here for example we have a
Sprinkles Cupcakes destination there's
all sorts of things that are only hue
everything that's in the link is more
affordable it's more accessible it's an
outdoor and indoor experience it's open
24/7 in the investment is a steep one
the whole project that includes the link
and the wheel was just under five
hundred million dollars now that's a lot
of money but where you have a building
right over there that was nearly 10
billion by Vegas standards not so much
by Vegas standards but still a lot of
money for a company that's dealing with
the twenty three billion dollar debt
load a hangover of a 2008 leveraged
buyout the same year The Hangover the
movie filmed at Caesars Palace to a
night the four of us will never forget
cherche in sweet but Loveman says
getting the money was actually pretty
easy this has been probably the simplest
thing to convince people of anything
I've dealt with since the financial
crisis as the company works to repair
its balance sheet winning back the
center strip is key to its success
competition is nervous I think the
competition is doing its own thing I
hope they are because that's what keeps
the biggest really says me really for
all of us we need to make sure that
Vegas is the key adult destination in
the United States